after trashing donald trump for his evil
america first stance
joe biden assembled his brain trust and
came up with something far
better america first here's joe from
today's times quote
i want to make sure we're going to fight
like hell by investing in america
first i'm not going to enter any new
trade agreement with
anybody until we have made major
investments here at home
and in our workers wow you know i'm old
enough to remember when joe felt
america first has made america alone
under the trump administration
our alliances are in jeopardy we're more
isolated in the world than we've ever
been our allies are
our goat alone our you know america
first has made america alone
president trump has changed the
landscape it's become
america first which meant america alone
yep
i also remember the day after the travel
ban and america first idea
when biden tweeted this we need to lead
the way with science
not donald trump's record of hysteria
xenophobia and fear-mongering
then what does joe do he backs the
travel ban three months late
so who's leading the way joe but we get
it if trump
did it it's evil until joe slowly
realizes it's not and then steals it
yeah he doesn't just lift speeches he'll
take the travel ban
the pro-fracking policy the vaccines
those tariffs on china
and also joe's preaching unity now a
trump rallying cry
after joe himself branded half of
america racist
and now it's america first joe suffers
from the
we hate trump but love is ideas disorder
you'll see more of it
the middle east peace plans higher wages
for the working class
defending law order joe will see what
trump's done and think
uh i can't do better and he's right so
joe's first term might in fact be trump
second
and everything the press condemned the
orange godzilla for
will become magically awesome under
mighty joe biden
joe should invent a slogan for this how
about
make america great again it has a nice
ring to it
so this is my theory jesse this is gonna
be if
if if it happens and joe ends up being
inaugurated it's just gonna be trump too
without the tweets i like it i like it
uh he's good at stealing things gutfeld
yes slogans elections all that stuff i'm
just kidding juan
thank you um you know he also
plagiarized uh his
build back better right he took that
from the united nations who knew they
had anything worth stealing
um i i'm gonna be honest if he steals
this i'm good with it me too
and i am gonna treat joe like i treated
trump
fair and balanced when he does something
good for the country i'm gonna applaud
him and he does something detrimental
i'm gonna savagely attack him
and and people will marvel about how
fair
i cover joe biden there you go and if
they call me a hypocrite if i did
something with trump that i didn't do
with biden
i will just wiggle my way out of it with
some reasonable explanation
but in all seriousness this made an
america thing that he's got on his
website which i looked at today
i mean it sounds exactly like trump's
plan it sounds great yeah they're going
to reinvest in manufacturing
they're not going to do these new
lopsided trade deals
they're going to buy america first all
that stuff
so let's see what happens juan what are
you going to do if he does something
that trump did are you going to actually
say
that's terrible or are you going to
suddenly like it i i think that's great
because i mean that's what i was going
to make jesse's point that if you guys
are really
saying oh this is 10 wait a minute you
liked what trump was doing so maybe you
should like what biden's but he should
accept that
no but in fact i thought you confused
things clearly
what you heard from biden was biden's
talking about military alliances
our involvement in nato climate deals uh
the asia pac
all that clearly trump pulled back and
let the rest of the world and our allies
left them
well that was part of america's first
but so my point is america
i look my point is biden won the
election
trump lost the american people rejected
trump and that's the bottom line here
and if you really want to think about it
i would say that you know
if you really think about america first
i think it was trump who didn't follow
through because we saw
billions in contracts go overseas during
the trump administration
oh we saw a lot of manufacturing jobs
come back today oh yeah not in
the left not enough we became a net oil
exporter
one of the first things he says he's
going to address when he rattles off in
this new york times interview
how he's going to review president
trump's policies is
energy so maybe that's an area where
he's going to make
some unwanted changes when you saw the
american worker and the american
consumer greatly benefit from that
energy independence
i think that what you have to factor in
there is the environment
and i think lots of people are and the
fact also
our emissions per capita in this country
are the lowest they've been since 1950
just broadly speaking they're the lowest
they've been since the early 90s
you know when you don't put america
first when you rejoin the paris accord
which puts us it hurts america and the
united states
and it actually lets china the biggest
co2 emitter
kick 10 years down the road before they
have to do anything
you know what doesn't put america first
raising corporate taxes
because if you raise corporate taxes in
this country which joe biden's promised
to do
above where the taxes are in china guess
what that encourages those corporations
to do
move those jobs overseas or build
factories overseas because there's a
lower tax rate there
they can move their headquarters over
there and you know how you really
screw rural americans who joe biden was
talking about you raise their gasoline
prices you raise their electricity
prices
and you take away their jobs in the
energy sector
i just want joe biden to say china virus
if he's going to borrow
borrow you know what from president
trump say
china plague because that's why 271
000 americans are dead that's why a
million and a half
people around the world are dead it's
because that virus came from china and
they lied about it and they
unleashed a pandemic on the world and
he's been blaming
trump shame on him i hate it when she
doesn't arrive
uh geared up for the show all right
what she came to play i think she's
gonna beat me up in the break and i will
probably enjoy it